[MUSIC]
Imagine, imagine that you're seeing
things that aren't there and you're
confused about time and place and you
quickly forget things that happen to you.
You're hallucinating, you're delirious,
you're suffering from amnesia,
if you were to walk into a doctor's
office with any of these symptoms,
you'd be declared psychopathic.
Maybe even placed in an institution,
and yet
all of us were in this state 12 hours ago,
we were sleeping.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
that's the seeming paradox of sleep.
It's the state to what's
selected by nature,
with a course of 3.6 million years,
and it makes no sense.
Think about it from an evolutionary
perspective, when you're sleeping,
you're not finding food,
you're clearly not reproducing,
you're not even fending for yourself.
You're totally vulnerable on any of
these grounds sleep should have been
strongly selected against, and yet here we
are three and a half million years later,
spending a third of our lives in
this state of flagrant psychosis.
If sleep doesn't serve
some truly vital function,
then it's the biggest mistake
the evolutionary process ever made.
We now know that sleep does have
many vital functions from cementing,
learning and consolidating memory,
to regulating emotion and
fostering the association
of disparate experiences.
And we also know that the vast majority
of us need between seven to nine hours of
sleep per night to function properly.
So why do we have such a hard time getting
the amount of sleep our brains so crave?
Well, because we live in a culture
that prices sleep machismo,
and we perpetuate a series of myths.
So let's talk about a couple of them.
So first myth, you might say,
I can go with five or
six hours of sleep per night and feel
just fine, and you'd be partially right.
There are some people that have a rare
genetic mutation that allows them to get
by with five hours or
less of sleep each night without
showing any signs of impairment.
However, according to Dr. Thomas Ruth
from the Henry Ford Hospital in Detroit,
the proportion of the population for
which this is the case,
rounded to the nearest whole number,
is zero.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's negligible, for
the rest of us insufficient sleep
can have serious consequences.
So let me tell you about an experiment.
Dr. David Dinges, the University of
Pennsylvania took two groups of people.
One of them was sleep deprived,
the other of whom was drunk,
drunk to the legal driving limit,
so 0.08% of blood alcohol.
And he gave both of these groups
a concentration test to assess cognitive
performance, what he found was that
have to just 19 hours of being awake,
19 hours, the sleep deprived group
was as cognitively impaired,
as the group that was legally drunk.
So think about what that means, imagine
you wake up on a Friday at 7 AM and
you go to work, and you spend your
day at work, then maybe you go out.
On the evening, on a date or
with friends, typical Friday, and
even if you drink no alcohol whatsoever,
by the time you're driving
back home at 2 in the morning,
you're essentially a drunk driver.
But you might say, wait I really do get
five or six hours of sleep per night,
the fact that I just got six hours of
sleep over the past few nights and
I feel great, I feel fantastic,
am I delusional?
And the answer is, yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes, you are.
>> Dr. Dinges experiment had a twist and
when he asked the sleep deprived group
how cognitively impaired they felt,
they significantly underestimated
their degree of disability.
In fact,
their self assessment was a terrible,
miserable predictor of just
how bad they performed.
Another major problem tied to this is
something called baseline resetting.
And it's been shown that after months or
years of chronic sleep deprivation, people
actually acclimate to their impaired
performance and reduced energy levels.
Never even realizing that they're
failing to maximize the potential of
mind and body.
Epidemiological studies suggest
that millions of people spend
years of their lives living like this.
So bottom line is, we don't know how sleep
deprived we are when we're sleep deprived,
and that's the scariest part of it all.
Now onto our second myth, we've all
probably set at some points in our lives,
I'll just sleep it off over the weekend.
And the research shows that just isn't
the case our brains are incapable of that.
So back to Dr. Dinges study,
after the initial test,
he took the sleep deprived group and
gave them three full recovery nights.
So three full nights of sleep,
then tested them again,
what do you think happened
the second time around?
Turns out that even after
three full recovery nights,
performance still did not return
to the original baseline levels.
Sleep just doesn't work like that,
fact we now know that lack of sleep
builds up and compounds over time, and
research even links to some of the most
feared diseases in the developed world.
One of them is Alzheimers.
Alzheimer's is triggered by
a metabolic toxin called beta amyloid,
which builds up naturally in our
brains over the course of the day, and
sleep offers a cleansing mechanism.
And so the less sleep you're
having across your lifespan,
the more of that toxic protein is building
up, night after night, year after year.
So when sufficient sleep is now considered
one of the most significant lifestyle
factors, determining whether or
not you'll develop the disease.
And for that reason, Dr.
Walker from Berkeley goes as far
as to call wakefulness,
a state of low level brain damage,
whereas sleep offers a repertory function.
Okay so sleep matters,
I hope you all agree with me on that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So what's the odd-shot?
What can we do to help
combat sleep machismo and
address the sleepless epidemic?
So first of at an individual level, there
is a tonne of research and literature out
there on insomnia and how to improve your
sleep, so I won't delve too much into it.
All I'll say is that by far
the best thing you can do for
your sleep is simply give
yourself an eight hour window.
No, it takes a meaningful
lifestyle change, but
it's totally worth it,
on the business level,
despite what we now know about sleep,
sleep machismo remains pervasive.
In fact, lack of sleep is often
even boasted as a badge of honor.
As an example, in my former job as
a consultant one of the lead partners in
the firm loved to have sleep as
one of his work/life balance KPIs.
And his aspirational metric to gauge
how much sleep he was getting was,
having no less than four and a half
hours of sleep per night on average,
four and a half hours, and
that was the aspiration.
Scores on mindset trickle down to the rest
of the team and the broader firm and
reinforce the stigmatization of sleep.
So from those overnight red eye flights
to the always on expectation and
the indefinite work schedules that often
drag beyond midnight, I believe that's
the merits a radical rethink of policies
and priorities in the business world.
Because awareness drives action and
change has to come from the top.
We've all heard the old maxim,
you can sleep when you're dead.
Let me tell you that is,
mortally unwise advice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We now know that the shorter you sleep,
the shorter you live, and
the quality of that now shorter life will
be much worse, sleep is not a paradox.
It is not a luxury reserved for
those of us without busy lives,
it is a biological necessity and
it is critical.
I sincerely hope that you'll
reflect on some of these learnings,
and if you don't, please just sleep on it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]